21 Jump Street 22 Jump Street the sequel
is that we waited about a year for this
and we got what we want is it funny well
here the rest of this video to find out
22 Jump Street
this film was [ __ ] awesome let me
like the first 30 minutes or so I was
like yeah it's enjoyable it's still kind
of funny and they kept making fun of the
fact that it was a sequel and that
they're gonna do like uh some rehashes
like they were you know I'm good show
but at the same time I was sort of like
feel like a rehash a little bit like
actuals
Scarface always game but there's a minor
twist that occurs in the film that will
completely shift everything around for
you 100% like I was hooked
what's really impressive about this film
to me is that it's a comedy sequel
that's actually really well made they
took all the bromance all the humor all
the action everything that worked in the
first one amplified it made it a much
faster pace film and gave us you know
not so much of a college experience
movie but more even like a kind of a
good cop investigation movie more look
just make this brief I'll just say this
if you like 21 Jump Street chances are
you're really gonna like 22 Jump Street
and if you don't shame on you
like you will it's at times it's very
funny some might say it's hilarious I
mean used that word in a while bring him
back the old ride Jonah Hill is back
doing his like insecure Jonah Hill thing
trying to is a really good job in the
film you know you didn't co-write this
one I'm like the last one but he still
[ __ ] delivers man like oh dude he has
his opening scene that I thought was
really funny it was like it was really
funny you really can't go into examples
in this film because it's a comedy but
just know there are some really funny
stuff what I'm really trying to
communicate here is there's some pretty
funny stuff Channing Tatum is back I
forgot how awesome this guy is in the
rules it's a real like badass
[ __ ] he's super [ __ ] charming
at the same time he's really funny one
of my favorite moments that I can't tell
you but just know this it's funny it's
really funny it's one of the funniest
scenes in the movie it's pretty funny
what I'm trying to really get through to
you is that scene is
really funny he's great he said I think
I might have liked it more in this one
than the last one but what really makes
this franchise work is not when you have
just Jonah Hill and Channing Tatum doing
the thing it's when they're together
doing their thing that chemistry is just
undeniable it's better than when Ben
Affleck and Jennifer Lopez did G Lee
together it's that's a hard
accomplishment in my opinion one of the
best bromances ever and like I said
earlier but I really like about this
film is that it's like a cool
investigation movie at first you're like
oh they're just doing what 21 Jump
Street did the same structure but even
though once while it's like a cool cop
film at the same time they never lose
the funny you gotta have funny cuz funny
is so important is just funny and you
need fun what I'm really trying to
communicate here is funny it's funny
they even included a block of ice more
see funny Ice Cube his actual birthday
he was way funnier in this film than he
was in the last one but they do think
they explored more okay yeah I'm not
gonna do that whole funny thing again
okay there's no one really new in this
film that truly stands out but the
script is still fantastic the direction
of these actors is perfect as the comedy
scenes play out so well and the pacing
it's actually I think it's significantly
faster than the last one and it has one
of the best closing credits scenes you
will ever see like the actual credits I
mean like the dude it is it just wait
just wait for this is a comedy so what
really matters are you gonna laugh or
not yes you will [ __ ] laugh or else
you are dead on the inside last thing I
want to say I'm proud to tell you this
is one of the funniest best comedy
sequels I've ever seen no I'm as good as
The Hangover Part two and three but
almost it let me get straight to the
point here oh and all I gotta say 22
Jump Street got it [ __ ] hilariously
right
alright guys thanks for checking out my
review for 22 Jump Street why don't you
go ahead scroll that comment box below
and tell me if you were unrecovered come
on throw out there you can follow me on
twitter he called the real rejects on
Twitter and all the other rejects - it's
pretty awesome
yeah Facebook vine and Instagram - last
but not least you going it updated every
time when we reviews or videos is out
going to click on this button about my
dick to subscribe [ __ ] Scarface the
dick well let me tell you something
about this little jumper over here he
has [ __ ] all kinds of Horrors on the
streets 22 of them to be exact
20 to 22 year olds to be exact this is
not even a joke dude this is facts